[Music]
welcome back to author record what are
we talking about
whatever
double man bun energy in the house baby
how do you get your bun in a bun what do
you mean what
you're the man genuine question how do
you get your hair in the bun
i need to learn how to do it i've never
tried it before you've never bunned it
up no i never did
bun would be super gangster right yeah
so beautiful i'm getting lost in the
game dude it's your hair
is it this right and then you just kind
of like uh when you're tying
a samurai ponytail no i got i got one
dog yeah i got one hold on
like once once you have it here it's
scrunchy oh yeah
well i got the scrunchie because uh the
scrunchie makes it look fuller than it
is the actual bun
because this is a black scrunchie
tactics yeah okay so
once you you tie the first part and you
bring it around
and you're doing this [ __ ] okay okay and
make sure it's nice and tight you gotta
do it in a wrap
yeah so i pull i pull it so it's like
the loop comes through so it's
not the whole thing just the little loop
pops up because i'm not fully i'm not as
long as yours
premature ejaculation on the hair yeah
it's a little little bit
but yeah you're right there's an
illusion going on it makes it look like
this is a full circle but is this right
yeah oh [ __ ] but you really got the puff
though you really got that kind of but
no you got it oh you're good you have
the tiniest little rubber band no that's
good
dude up here is like a period piece in a
chinese movie
i look like a chinese guy triple man bun
energy let's go let's go steve your turn
uh well
that was very difficult
very very very difficult for me i was
actually about
i got a haircut this morning and i was
planning on cutting it off
but but what happened i just had an
audition where the
part the dude's hair was long so if i
get it i want to make sure my hair is
still long you know what i'm saying but
it's if you find that you don't get it
you can cut it off in anger
yeah no i'm i definitely will i mean who
knows who knows
a person or is it uh that's all self
tape but like hair seppuku
aren't you so glad to finally self tape
everything self tape yeah because i'm
really bad in the room
are you really like i uh you suck at
auditions yeah you know how like
like i'm a smart person but i'm bad at
no well okay so like i didn't do
homework but i was good at test taking
so it was like opposite for auditions
i'm saying like when you give me the
part when they're like yo i have a part
for you
i kill that [ __ ] right but when
auditions when it's
in the room in person auditions i always
like i feel like i'm i'm nervous and
it's awkward
it's so awkward you have like you're
trying to be emotional and the person
reading lines with you is just like
okay you're like saying jokes and like
okay
you know do you do the do you do like
the actual homework though like you
break it down like crazy and you spend
like a couple days on the sides i don't
i try to be memorized now because i
remember
in the beginning i didn't realize
auditions were so like i didn't know
they wanted you to be off book you feel
me so i would be in the room with the
script until my agent was like yo
try to get off book i was like [ __ ] man
i know it's so serious that's like my
forte
what my book really
he's off off book what he's saying is he
has to memorize
and not on the script you're just
improvising yeah yeah yeah yeah
so now i don't even got to book the book
i'm on laptop and [ __ ]
so now even for self tapes like at home
i'm still memorized yeah
that makes that dude anytime i didn't i
used to do it
same [ __ ] where i coming with the script
in my hand though i'm like doing a lot
of [ __ ] but then
when you're actually auditioning people
and you see them do that
you're like oh it doesn't look good yeah
you have that little moment to yourself
of like oh [ __ ] it doesn't it just
doesn't work
and if there's 12 other people that kill
it you're like no wonder i didn't get
picked with no script
yeah i just love the idea that like
robert de niro's in there like one more
want to see their auditions those guys
are probably just they sleepwalk through
that [ __ ]
do you think those guys still audition
or they just [ __ ] no so i read that
marlon brando right
he used to say that like scripps felt so
fake so
because he's like people don't you don't
think in premeditated lines right
so he would have an earpiece in the
scene and
when each person said they're lying he
would have somebody reading his next
line to him in his ear and he would just
say it like that but that's after he
already got the part that was actually
he was already like
[ __ ] i think he's more than brand new
yeah
dude i watched um you guys you guys
watched the um ex
what was it expendables or whatever the
[ __ ] it was with uh still i was
i mean steven's no sylvester stallone
yeah but there was all of them
wasn't mickey work in that yeah he's not
one of them yeah so there was a scene
there was a scene in there where i could
tell that mickey work is like tattooing
a guy
and he's like a tattoo artist or
whatever and i could tell that he just
had his lines on the guy's back and he's
just [ __ ] reading his lines on the
guy's back always pretending that's
hilarious amazing you guys watch the
friends reunion
yes so i didn't know but like you know
courtney cox was saying how like she
used to write the lines on the table
yeah yeah and then uh joey would always
come and just erase it
yeah that's when she was writing all the
lines oh that's hilarious that's tight
yeah [ __ ] but they're that hard yeah
yeah cause like you know like for those
it's not like one script that you shoot
for six months
it's a weekly episode so there's lines
all the [ __ ] time and then so i think
you don't have time to memorize them all
she's like i'm just gonna write on plus
if you're in like season
four already you know what i mean for
sure you're [ __ ] with your co-stars
if they're like the only people always
a million dollars an episode you need a
break
security as hell million and episodes
that's every week and that eventually
you don't even need to do crypto at that
point
[ __ ] no they probably should i always
think about how like the harry potter
kids they really just had to secure one
audition and they were set for life
for sure and then it was like eight
movies from they were like 10 to 30. you
know i don't even know if they were
securing auditions or like a dude walked
in it's like
that looks like harry yeah yeah i mean
like daniel radcliffe was like
how are you auditioning like it's like a
life of pie kid
he didn't even audition it was his
brother or some [ __ ] and then he came to
just
support his audition they're like we
want you for real
damn brothers is pissed for life or was
it slumdog millionaire it's one of those
pie yeah is it life of pie okay ah man
it's a struggle you know it's like uh
so i've been doing mad self tapes and
it's like uh you send them in and just
kind of wait does chia help you
yeah i mean we have no choice so um i
mean they always prefer i feel like they
prefer if you have somebody reading with
you
so now especially since we have the baby
yeah how do you tell the baby to shut up
we make sure that the baby is on she is
titty while we're doing the [ __ ] so
she's holding the camera
i'm on the tripod she is like over here
breastfeeding with the laptop in front
of her
dog there was there was literally one
audition where like i was like this is
the best we're gonna be able to get
because the baby was like really just
had a lot of energy
and so i would like i would say my line
and then
she would say her line and then you
would hear like in the background i
would wait and then
and then see my line you know what i'm
saying wow yeah i didn't get it
because of the baby how many auditions
do you do
like uh like a year or a month or
whatever well you know what i think
maybe because
productions are kind of opening up again
like i this has been a good month like
i've done like
three or four in the past couple weeks
um and uh
so it's been kind of popping like it's
cool lately i mean you know i haven't
booked any but you know it's silly
it's still popping it's still popping oh
always no no i'm just i'm blessed to be
getting oh you know what someone [ __ ]
up the other day guys so my um someone
from my like
uh my agent uh my agency they sent a
script right
and they were like okay they want you to
read for this part
and they sent like 10 scripts in the
email and i was like yo is there like
i know they're not having me read 10 uh
10 scenes right
and so he was like oh no that's a
mistake for some reason they sent 10
scripts so i looked at the thing
and i finally looked and it they sent
all the scripts with the names of the
other people they sent
the auditioning yeah bro it was like me
[ __ ] bobby lee um jim the mc
like a bunch of these other asian dudes
couple racists
one [ __ ] sexy ass asian dude though
in some other movie i'm like all right
what
what part what are they looking for for
this you know but
so random super they don't even know
yeah
that's just give me all the asians you
got pretty much
so you know i'm glad i'm i'm on that
like that list though at least
that's tight i mean it's a blessing
what's the whackest role that you've
gotten auditioned for where you're like
[ __ ] with someone auditioning
yeah you were turned down like they like
we got you we want you and you're like
nah nah never mind
um well there's nothing super wack
because i told my agent from the
beginning i'm like
you know i don't want to do anything
like stereotypical you know what i'm
saying nothing
to there was always like ripping up
straight up okay just ripping all the
rolls
they have they have the script for
karate man there's put it in the trash
can
there was one movie specifically all
right
it was it was basically like presented
to me
and but the producer who's like kind of
like a big dude about i was cool with
him and he's like hey i want you to read
for this part
and i read the script and the script was
like
um you know at first it was kind of
saying like oh okay this dude's kind of
like you know nerdy cameraman i was like
all right i usually don't want to do
that but i'm like all right let me just
read the rest of the script right
and then there's a scene like the guy
gets beat up i'm like ah i don't know if
i want to
huh and then there's literally a scene
where the script says
the guy gets pants and he's like hanging
out of a car and it says like
his his small penis is flapping in the
wind and i was like bruh
i was like bro send this to ken jong
dude he's a small he wants to do these
kind of roles
yeah this is what he wants i haven't
seen him clothed in a movie in a long
time
yeah dude yeah and i would not do that
you know sounds like girl i can't
bless a bro i can't do this he was like
would you want to he's like what do you
want to do like the
i was like bro if i did this it would
undo everything i've been doing over the
past ten years i'm sorry did i not just
watch a playlist of skeet skeet skeet
videos
i'll skeet skeet skeet but not from not
uh
perpetuating stereotypes all right wait
what's the stereotype there
i'm not sure okay cool uh karate
is having your butt out it's a karate
man today's video is brought to you by
upstart these days
everyone's freaking out because crypto
is going a little bit down
and all the people who was waiting to
collect some profits on crypto
have to wait a little bit longer a
little bit too
long a little bit longer such as me
right so in this situation you know i
had to use a credit card and i had to
buy things and um
yeah it's got a high apr i don't like
that
no thank goodness for things like
upstart here
where i can get a loan for possibly a
lower apr than my credit card
and i can transfer that loan which is
maybe about 20
into something much much lower and you
can also get approved
the next day oh yeah get up to 50k
really quickly upstart is awesome it's
an alternative
to getting a loan amount versus your
credit card or any other type of loan
and on top of that they know you're just
more than a credit score
okay because most of these places they
judge you
on your credit score only but upstart
they look at everything like do you got
a job
what kind of money you making also do
you have a degree
how reliable are you and they know every
human being has
different criteria like that that makes
them
reliable so if you're looking for
another way to lower
your monthly payments or to pay off that
one-off thing that you need
go to upstart.com off the record and
check to see if upstart can help you
and the loan amount that you're going to
get is going to be based off your credit
score your income and all the other
information you fill in your application
so make sure you go to upstart.com off
the record thank you bye
bye-bye pulls the karate man's script
back out
better karate man i'd probably do at
this point
so that was one thing i was like i can't
do that i like how he was like what part
won't you do
[ __ ] ken john though i always watch i
always watch um
where's he been hangover he's hosting
like three different game shows oh
and i'm always like bro like if that was
me i would at least
like have my dick like fluffed a little
bit you know what i'm saying like get a
little hard or like shorter hair so that
you can get
but i guess that was the joke or a
prosthetic one because i think jonah
hill and uh
wolf on wall street he just had a fake
one when he was getting like when he's
jerking off at the party
was it i don't even know that he doesn't
have to show his real dick i wouldn't
have known
i would've known either but i saw an
interview so i'm guessing the prosthetic
one's probably larger than his real one
so i'm guessing ken john could have done
a way different
heroic act for us asians do you think he
volunteered for that he's like i'll show
my dick or do was it like
we'll give you a prosthetic he's like
haha yes this is funny i want to show my
dick
i was pissed that there was like no no
types of
no type of dick at all coming out it was
like i mean in hangover
and that that had to that had to be a
joke right but in hangover two
they made justice because those uh asian
guys had some pretty big dicks
this is true i blocked that movie out of
my head bro you know what though
he's like is this a magic show that's my
favorite line of the whole movie
i didn't like hangover 2 because i felt
like it was such a copy paste of the
first one yeah
but but he said i come in you you come
on floor
that's the best line ever i've never
seen a movie where the first one was so
[ __ ] good and then the second
one was just so whatever i was just i
was very disappointed
no but hangover three was really good
did you watch it what was that i did see
it i loved it i don't remember i don't
remember yeah where was that
it was so completely different but where
did it go wait there was
that the tyson one or no i remember an
open with a giraffe getting his head cut
off on the freeway and i was like what
the [ __ ] is going on
that's that's all i remember that was
three in number three i didn't know
there was a three
there's no you gotta watch three because
three is such a different like
number three um someone
wants to kidnap ken jong right and then
there's like a whole [ __ ] twist where
this dude is like yo kim jong stole my
gold he has half my gold
and then so kim jong is like all right
yo my gold is hidden um is like in my
basement at this house you gotta break
into my house cause i'm locked out of it
is that what john goodman yeah yeah yeah
so they break into the house and then
spoiler alert
you can watch it oh they break it to the
house and they steal their
they steal the rest of the gold and then
and then john goodman's like you
[ __ ] that was my house you just
stole the rest of my gold that i already
had and it was a whole fl it's crazy
though you gotta watch okay okay i'm
sorry
it's time you're watching spoiler alert
remember the giraffe part and then i
literally turned to my buddy and i was
like what the [ __ ] going on and that's
the last thing i remember about that
movie
it's way better than it's blacked out
afterwards or what i just don't remember
anything they need to get the producers
from fast and furious on so they can
make
over nine like three four five six seven
eight nine just getting on crazier and
crazier
they all become [ __ ] secret agents
and no kung fu that's what they gotta
save the world as long as you add the
rock it's gonna be
you know no he's gonna come in later
though yeah yeah you gotta earn it
yeah you can't start with e9 straight to
it
and he joins definite success movies
like or franchises oh the rock
yeah dude i'm
uh i read the other day that uh warner
brothers wants to explore the
possibility of
fast and furious uh jurassic world
crossover
i've heard that i'm hyped saying you're
hyped that's what we want
about it that's what i want i love how
ridiculous the fast and furious movies
keep getting
i think it's like dope and hilarious and
so they got to fight the dinosaurs now
yeah yeah yeah yeah
or heist with the dinosaurs we don't
know yeah there's gonna be like a
dinosaur that's on their side tyrese is
gonna randomly be [ __ ] just riding
one yeah you know what i mean
i'm pretty sure like they're gonna
combine forces with like the overboard
dinosaurs or whatever
the ones that don't kill humans on them
and they're gonna ride a stegosaurus or
some [ __ ]
and vin diesel's going to get eaten but
he's going to open the [ __ ] t-rex
he's going to slice it open from the
belly no wife beat her completely
like normally still white and just throw
it
oh yeah dude i need to see yeah fast and
furious time traveling i'm
in bro i'm [ __ ] in all the way yeah
why not
let's just go all the way like they can
fly they just did space right the new
one they think so
it's rumored that like 10 is supposed to
be in space for some [ __ ] oh it's set in
space
not or nine hasn't come out yet not yet
it's out
it's out i'm trying no no no what's his
face dante just said he was going to go
screening tonight no i know but it's out
in china though
it came out in china [ __ ] china yeah
probably they're so awesome
nice we love china here
so yeah but that's that's the whole
thing is what are they going to do next
so that would be great
you know who tried to do something like
that was um jonah hill he was trying to
do that for the um
what was those movies he's doing with
their he was trying to do men in black
crossover yeah where like those guys
become mibs after having being popped
that would have been fun it would be
awesome but they got shut down by the
studios
it's too creative jurassic world
f9 oh there it is
because they can't oh both of the new
jurassic park movies like i liked them
but they were kind of the same they're
just a good time yeah it's just a fun
time
a good time that's a good one
automobiles into it then we're talking
oh i'm in bro
it would've been like great straight to
hbo max type stuff you know what i mean
like 10 out of 10
but like maybe like 7.5 out of 10 there
was some mortal kombat in there come on
dude we got a whole movie bro
why not what's stopping it what's
stopping us i want to know that vin
diesel has secretly trained the
pterodactyl
and it's in his backyard like tied to a
car and no dog i want them to take vin
diesel dna
and inject it into a t-rex and then at
the end
at the end he's drinking a beer with the
t-rex he's like me familiar
i'm in you know the t-rex has vin diesel
cause he's gonna have a tank top on
v-rex [ __ ] v-rex dude
v-racks dude that'll be something in a
tank top that's
crazy dude why is why is dom toretto
like the center
of the the universe in these movies
probably because he's the executive
producer i don't know how i laughed yeah
he's like the most famous person in the
world in those movies like everyone
knows who the [ __ ] he is
it's awesome it's so great i know i love
it
and paul walker died he reminds me of
steven seagal kind of
well i get kind of vibes off of that
dude where he's just like all right dude
i'm kind of sick and tired of dom
doretto chronicle's a riddick guy
yeah bro iron giant dude oh was he the
iron jacket he was the roger
that's right one of his best roles yeah
that was
you know what's crazy about groot is
that you guys probably noticed already
but
all the script the script gets sent to
vin diesel with
actual dialogue what like so he'll read
a line that says like
i miss you dad and he goes i am groot
or it's like it's like or it's like dude
or the line will say like let me play my
video games because i am groot
right it's all real dialogue and then he
just like
reads it as if he was grouped what a
genius way to just reinterpret the lines
you gotta memorize [ __ ]
that's really acting right there i
wonder who the writers are it was like
they just know that this is gonna happen
anyway though what the [ __ ] am i doing
there yeah
there's a director that goes come on can
you do that with more emotion
yeah can you say it's sadder or vin's
getting frustrated with himself in the
recording
he's like i'm in
that's crazy oh yeah i need that
crossover i'm pretty into that
yeah so that'd be pretty crazy epic
what's another good crossover that's the
future man karate kid and mortal kombat
yeah yeah that's two kills on getting
[ __ ] in a pitch perfect
oh yeah you gotta [ __ ] each other up and
sing
yeah you're gonna have like uh
[ __ ] fatality power rangers and pitch
perfect
but they sing in their helmets it sounds
weird but they still move their faces
they're like
batman superman
probably not a good call thank you [ __ ]
there was that like ninja turtles and
power rangers had like an episode where
they
had a problem that was fun you know it
was like new it was like the newer ninja
turtles like the imax one they had like
a power rangers meetup i i didn't see
the episode i only saw
the gif uh online but it looked cool
what about seinfeld and x-men
oh yeah that would be pretty good
[Laughter]
crazy uh here's a fun fact about
seinfeld
in the first like season or whatever
because you know how like they they used
to do you guys watching that film
okay so yeah watch like the first season
or two x-men
first season or two jerry opens up with
like uh stand up right and you know you
and then you hear the little thing
now i'm playing so um there's a
keyboardist that used to have to play
according to jerry's stand up every time
because it was always different
stan like like what he was saying was
always different and different like
timing so it was a keyboardist that
would always have so like every episode
of of the first like season whatever
was different because there was a guy
like playing along with like
jerry would be like oh you know hey
what's up with why can't we be naked
he's like connect
[Music]
damn he was a soundtrack like your job
was a soundtrack for a stand-up comedian
yeah
and then they ditched that and then they
got enough samples
push the button dude sarcasm
um women that probably makes sense
though huh
probably automated afterwards you see
that that was ryan anime who was hard
cause he could play anything
[Music]